I don't think any of them are Red Bull
are you guys messing with me Stanley Cup
blind taste test kis find a Red
Bull oh that's brutal I don't know what
that is what you put in that it's like
protein powder and
vodka that's brutal
too that might be
sugarfree and the other tastes are kind
of throwing me off I think it's not
number one final answer you want
to no it might be it might be so it's
number four yeah okay all right there
you go you can tell it's sugarfree it's
sugar free kind of is it sugar free it's
one sugarfree and one regular okay so
there's definitely sugar that is a taste
test right there ladies and gentlemen I
know what's going on that's a pallet
that is a pallet that you can count on